turning now to the death of a teenager
at the hands of police in illinois
newly released police camera footage
reveals some of what happened just
before an officer fired
the deadly shots last week in waukegan
19-year-old marcela stinnett was killed
and his girlfriend tafara williams
wounded
williams says they did nothing wrong
police say they were unarmed
but they also say that the two tried to
hit an officer with their car
that officer has since been fired
adriana diaz now reports
body camera footage shows an officer
approach tafara williams and marcellus
to net in a parked car
and identify them by name you're
marcellus right
yeah you you're under arrest man why
because i said
marshalls you're under arrest
because you got a warrant the officer
didn't say what the warrant was for
and marcellus's girlfriend in the
driver's seat takes off
and they just ran me over at one point
the car reverses off camera
then you hear a crash and roughly six
[Music]
gunshots
only after the shooting did that second
officer turn on his body camera
i was right behind her you almost tried
to run me over the police department
says that officer's life may have been
in danger the vehicle that he was
investigating began
to reverse towards the officer williams
said she lost control of the car
family members joined an emotional press
conference wednesday
where sinnette's grandmother broke down
attorneys for williams questioned the
timing of the body camera activation
this officer had his oh crap moment
after the shooting and push the button
so he knew
to push the button and shortly
thereafter say
you tried to run me over according to
the mayor's office
the officer was fired in part for
failing to properly activate his body
camera
a breach of department policy williams
is in the hospital recovering from
gunshot wounds to the abdomen in hand
i told them please don't shoot i have a
baby
we have a baby we don't want to die
an officer dragged me away from our
sellers
they laid marcellus on the ground and
covered them up with a
blanket while he was still breathing
he later died at the hospital for cbs
this morning
adriana diaz chicago
that's why it's so important to have the
body cams but it's really
maddening to hear that okay i didn't
turn it on or i turned it on right after
everything happened it
defeats the whole purpose it does it's
got to be a way to do this without
people dying there had to be another way
to do that